[Music]
Lebanon is on the brink of economic
collapse the local currency has lost
more than 80 percent of its value on the
black market food prices have
skyrocketed leaving Lebanese from all
walks of life unable to put food on the
table I'm Natalia ng let me do the best
but she some have resorted to bartering
to meet their basic needs two recent
suicides have been linked to hardship
caused by the crisis people talk about
socio-economic crisis what do we have at
hand in Lebanon this humanitarian crisis
and if the current trend persists the
government warns 60% of the population
could fall into poverty by the end of
2020 so how did we get here
Lebanon is the third most indebted
country in the world its economy has
been in freefall for years recently the
government failed to make a 1.2 billion
dollar payment for foreign bonds the
first such default in Lebanon's history
government mismanagement and corruption
are rampant over the years governments
in Lebanon have used the banking system
to finance unsustainable spending
critics say this put the money of
ordinary Lebanese citizens in jeopardy
and they're now bearing the brunt of the
country's financial meltdown since
October banks have largely limited the
amount of US dollars clients can
withdraw from their own accounts about
three-quarters of all deposits and
Lebanese banks are in US dollars and
with the local currency losing its value
the consequences have been disastrous
with many fearing their earnings and
savings are now gone successive
governments have failed to provide basic
services so it's just 24/7 electricity
and garbage collection
sharp John sharp Tehran sharp yes in
Shaba Samburu a condo Alamo a
photographer yet oh ha ha - OH when Adam
soliton an Valastro Oh Bogdanovich my
una with my sharp colors fudge Alicia
cluster many say Lebanon's corruption is
fueled by its very own political system
Lebanon is a sectarian democracy which
ensures that different religious groups
are represented in government critics
say this encourages patronage and helped
create a political class that looks
after its own sex interests rather than
those of the whole country by October
2019 the people had had enough
[Music]
Lebanon witnessed its biggest popular
uprising in years
targeting corruption and the political
system itself partner yoni helmets of
the seven detainee the government
responded by resigning any new
government was formed earlier this year
but little has changed and people
accused the current government of being
out of touch with their problems in this
local TV report the government Minister
visits a supermarket and as herself
shocked by the crisis right again
senator
- so what now everyone agrees Lebanon
needs help fast
the government is negotiating a multi
billion dollar bailout from the
International Monetary Fund but concerns
over stalled reforms are making it
difficult
with hundreds of thousands of Lebanese
having lost their jobs since October
help cannot come fast enough
[Music]
you